un benhaim vous êtes magnifique quel est
votre secret de beauté les
téléspectateurs nous demande tous les
jours c'est vrai quel est le secret
beauté de valérie bds l'amour non mais
ce nom un travail non réjouit avec
d'éclat malade que j'aime
moi je connais votre secret de bourbon
s'élève valérie bénaïm c'est l'amour
c'est l'amour que vous portez à votre
fils c'est pas top je sais qu'ils en
attendent un deuxième un coucou frontier
algérie je sais que non mais c'est vrai
supporter un amour incroyable à votre
fils c'est vrai je t'embrasse votre
office avec qui vous êtes allé en
vacances à new york
je sais que vous voulez mais énormément
mais sachez que votre fils on a été le
rencontrer aujourd'hui et il aimerait
que vous lâchez un peu parce qu'il est
grand maintenant voilà vous l'amener en
vacances et avec vous m en voulais
amener encore au parc alors qu'il a 45
ans il fait du manège c'est bon quoi
donc regarder votre fils en a marre il a
souhaité garder l'anonymat
[Rires]
c'est pareil maintenant vos pattes après
midi me fait faire du vélo et des
roulettes
ils soient ses suppôts et au lit je suis
plus un gamin merde non non j'ai fini le
mien mais suit y est maman ou paddock